on va retrouver à présent jérôme marty
médecin et président du syndicat unef ml
l'union française pour une médecine
libre bonsoir jérôme marty merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors on attendait beaucoup le président
évidemment sur le personnel soignant et
le travail extraordinaire réalisé
pendant cette crise
emmanuel macron à remercier évidemment à
cette mobilisation extraordinaire des
services de santé mais où en est-on de
ce ségur de la santé qui a été initiée
le 25 mai dernier avec olivier verrons
qu'en est il aujourd'hui pour l'instant
on en a plein de choses puisqu'on n'est
pas vraiment rentrer dans le dur il ya
eu des réunions qui ont été annulés
annulé au dernier moment on comment
s'appellent les discussions
vraisemblablement ou est-ce que ça va
mener très difficile à dire on a bien
entendu le président de la république
qui a parlé de donner plus de liberté
aux soignants mais dans quelles
conditions
dans quel cadre tout cela reste
relativement vague tant qu'on ne sera
pas sorti en fait de ce lien
administratif extrêmement puissant que
l'on peut avoir avec les agents des
douanes de santé et avec l'état qui est
quand même la main sur la santé tente en
médecine de ville la médecine
hospitalière
on n'aura pas un nouveau schéma et donc
qu'on n'aura pas une nouvelle
organisation a sauté est-ce que
néanmoins les indications que le chef de
l'état a donné ce soir vous satisfont
investissements également un promis par
le chef de l'état de nouveaux
investissements
la voûte et on ne peut que là on a envie
de le croire a envie de suivre ce qui
dit quand il parle tels des pandas ce
mot qui nous est cher quand il quand il
parle de refonder en quelque sorte
l'avenir de la phrase d'aller vers les
énergies nouvelles peut aller vers une
écologie solidaire et ça ça fait partie
également de la santé donc de notre
mission on a envie de croire le seul
problème c'est que par exemple lorsqu'il
parle de scinder ses 100 milliards ont
été dépensés pour soutenir les
entreprises pour soutenir l'économie
française la vraie question et se
demandent s il lui fallut 500 milliards
si nous avions lu les masques et si nous
avions eu les tests si nous avons eu des
ddd des milliers de lits de réanimation
qui nous ont manqué si la france en bref
avait été mieux préparés certainement
cette prise pour écouter
richert donc tout ça ça montre qu' il
faut sortir de cette politique qui
jusqu'à présent a régit la santé parce
que cette politique nous a menés dans le
mur
alors oui on a envie de quoi mais lui il
va falloir qu'ils nous donnent des gages
qu'il nous montre des actes qui vont
nous laisser croire en fait il nous
laissait entendre que véritablement on
reporte vraiment ceux qui encadrent
jusqu'à présent la santé que l'on donne
une part du pouvoir ce mot est peut-être
dur mais c'est celui ci qu'il faut une
part du pouvoir et d'organisation aux
soignants sur la somme est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le chef de l'état qui
parle d'une victoire finalement après
cette première étape de déconfinement il
aurait dû davantage faire un mea culpa
justement sur ces manquements dont vous
parlez au début de la crise non je crois
que on peut pas parler de victoire
d'abord on était au litre on aurait
quand même du mal à parler des victoires
alors qu'on a plus de 30000 morts qu'on
n'a pas comptabilisé encore l'été c'est
qu'ils se sont fait à domicile alors
qu'ont à 46 médecins libéraux qui sont
décédés et médecins hospitaliers qu'on a
encore des soignants qui sont en
réanimation que on a eu tous et tous et
poussez donc ces milliers de morts
quoique on va parler de victoire on peut
parler par contre de l'engagement fort
d'une responsabilité forte devant le
soin qui a été celle des soignantes
d'une responsabilité qui a été celle de
tous les français de faire qu' on puisse
sortir de ce confinement qui a été de
respecter les consignes on a vu que l on
était relativement à majorité respecter
et puis une sortie d'un film ans qui a
débuté donc le 11 mai qui doit
s'accélérer peur avec que l'ensemble des
français qui doit jouer chacun doit
jouer son rôle pour relancer l'économie
française c'est plus de cela que dont il
faut parler c'est plus de cette
responsabilité française cet engagement
des français que d'une victoire je crois
qu'on est tous on a été contraint à ce
combat on a été contraint à faire face
et on se serait bien passé mais encore
une fois ce n'était pas une guerre
c'était un combat pour la vie et ce
combat pour la vie qui a été menée par
les français pendant cette crise
emmanuel macron à remercier d'ailleurs
ceux qui ont continué à travailler les
soignants bien évidemment il a parlé
aussi
des aînés il a parlé des jeunes il a
annoncé donc la réouverture là le
passage en zone verte maintenant pour
toute la métropole à partir de demain on
va écouter le chef de l'état qui met en
garde néanmoins le virus est toujours là
at il dit nous allons retrouver
pleinement la france cela ne signifie
pas que le virus a disparu et que nous
pouvons baisser totalement lagarde
il nous faudra pour longtemps encore
vivre avec lui respecter les règles de
distance physique l'été 2020 ne sera pas
un été comme les autres et il nous
faudra veiller à l'évolution de
l'épidémie pour nous préparer au cas où
elles reviendraient avec plus de force
la lutte contre l'épidémie n'est donc
pas terminée mais je suis heureux avec
vous de cette première victoire contre
le virus le jérôme marty est ce que les
français peuvent reprendre une vie quasi
normale on va dire oui je vois qu'ils
peuvent reprendre une vie normale mais
comme le dit manuel macro et il a raison
en gardant à l'esprit qu'il va falloir
continuer à respecter un certain nombre
de gestes barrières et puis surtout il
faut connaître ce virus il faut
apprendre à l'étudier il faut se
préparer et il faut savoir réagir si
tenté que malheureusement l'épidémie
reprenait après les vacances horizons au
kop horizon novembre ou décembre ne sais
pas personne aujourd'hui est capable de
le dire ce qu'on sait c'est que le
terrain de jeu de ce virus c'est la
terre entière
on voit bien qu'il ya des pays où celui
ci se développe fortement des pays où
ils réémerge nous nous sommes dans une
période qui est très calme où le virus
est repassé en quelques sortes soit
boisseau même s'il ya un certain nombre
de clusters que l'on découvre pas ce
conte est beaucoup plus le virus
continue à circuler à bas bruit
donc il faut il fait partie de nous il
va falloir apprendre à vivre avec lui et
après la ville aurait glissé respecter
pour jour un certain nombre de gestes
barrière alors justement on attendait
aussi le chef de l'état pour savoir si
l'arsenal est prêt en cas de rebond de
cette épidémie charles arsenal puisque
le chef de l'état a parlé d'une guerre
est ce que selon vous on est prêt alors
il ya des masques il ya des tests mais
est ce qu'on est prêt à l'hôpital jérôme
marty à accueillir de nouveaux
l'adp si le virus revenait à l'automne
oui on les oléo des beaucoup plus prêts
que nous l'avons été faut pas oublier
quand même comme malheureusement une des
principaux cluster c'est l'hôpital
puisque l'hôpital était au départ mal
préparé et beaucoup de soignants ont été
contaminés et donc les fous dans les
foyers de contamination il ya l'hôpital
ce n'est certainement plus le cas
aujourd'hui parce que les matériels sont
enfin arrivées et puis les personnels
soignants sont aguerris à la lutte
contre le pauvre 19 c'est la même chose
dans les établissements médico sociaux
dans les ehpad dans les cliniques
privées dans les sprints suite
les personnels ont appris à faire face
la médecine libérale également donc nous
sommes prêts nous sommes prêts s'il
devait y avoir un nouvel assaut de ces
virus nous saurons réagir et les
français également ont appris à le
connaître on appris à vivre avec lui
c'est pour ça que en quelque sorte nous
pourrons réagir beaucoup plus vite et
sans doute sans doute par cet
apprentissage
arriverons nous empêcher l'importance
d'une deuxième balle
quand vous dites que vous êtes prêt ça
veut dire qu'il y aurait davantage de
lille il ya des respirateurs il ya des
des produits anesthésiants tout ce qui
faisait défaut en tout cas absence ça
vous savez bien que non pour l'instant
on est toujours un bel youri de matériel
notamment dans l'esthétique et le dépôt
de produits qui servent aux gestes à la
réanimation qui sont encore à flux tendu
qui ont été mis en réserve par l'état
qui arrive avec relativement parcimonie
les lits de réanimation non il y en a
pas plus vous le savez les cours sur
cinq mille civils dit il faudra sans
doute rentrer davantage mais c'est dans
cet intervalle de temps les quelques
mois qui viennent que doit se faire
cette politique de relance véritable
vis-à-vis de l'hôpital public et de
relance véritable vis-à-vis de la
médecine de ville
il va falloir apprendre à compter
autrement qu'avec le souci économique eu
le souci de ne pas investir dans la
santé le falher au contraire investir
massivement en quelque sorte
l'austérité récente et doit prendre fin
on doit penser l'europe aux mêmes qui
soigna qui sortent
celle qui demain pour vous éviter une
nouvelle progression et ses personnels
soignants réclamer aussi une
revalorisation des salaires qui n'ont
pas pour l'instant obtenu ils ont ils
ont des promesses en ce sens en tout cas
c'est une annonce qu aurait dû faire
également le chef de l'état je parle
aussi des stagiaires
qui ont beaucoup contribué à aider dans
les hôpitaux et qui ont été sous payés
mais c'est tout le tout le monde de
soignants vous savez le monde soignant
il n'ya pas d'ailleurs que les soignants
et d'écourter profession qui permettent
de faire tourner les hôpitaux
il s'agit des ae sage de bombardier dans
les soignants les exfoliante jusqu'aux
médecins les chirurgiens les
anesthésistes les infirmières c'est tout
le personnel soignant qui doit être
aujourd'hui mieux considérées ce mot de
considération est extrêmement importante
parce que bien sûr il ya les tarifs bien
sûr il à la rémunération mais il ya
aussi la considération et la
considération ça veut dire qu'il faut
accepter de déléguer un certain nombre
de pouvoirs que cette seule fois
administratif doit laisser un certain
nombre de pouvoirs aux soignants de
façon à ce que ce soit le soin qui
orientaient la destinée des hôpitaux le
soin qui on regarde la destinée de la
médecine de ville et non pas encore une
fois des contraintes budgétaires
merci beaucoup un jérôme marty vous
auriez aimé pour finir entendre en
entendre davantage de la part du
président dans les côtés je crois il a
dit qu'il allait refaire un point au
mois de juillet 10 le mois de juillet
c'est donc dans un mois on va voir le
mois comment les choses ont évolué et on
aura d'ailleurs les premiers rendus du
ségur de la santé oms aura davantage mon
année on espère que les leçons devant
être tirées de cette crise majeure
aujourd'hui nous rentrons dans une crise
économique qui est gravissime pour le
pays
chacun va devoir faire face je crois que
là encore une fois on avait parlé d'
équipe de phrases pour lutter contre le
pauvre 19 falloir parler l'équipe de
france pour lutter comme ça et on en
reparlera évidemment en juillet lorsque
le président vous prendra la parole on
refera un nouveau bilan merci beaucoup
jérôme marty d'avoir analysé cette
allocution présidentielle pour rt france